[Music]
what's up guys i'm going to show you a
money making guide that requires no
requirements except maybe just a little
bit of cash so we're going to come down
here in Katherine B which is you can
just teleport to Camelot and then come
down here and then trade the shopkeeper
guy and then the value of these are just
one coin so we're going by all of them
because it'll only be two coins and then
we go ahead and hop world and once you
to the new world trade them again and
just go ahead and buy more so I'm going
to do this and do a full inventory and
start the timer and then i'll see you
guys want to have a full inventory
alright i'm back and it took about two
minutes to get a full inventory so now
i'm gonna go to the GE alright guys i'm
back in i thought i was recording but i
wasn't so sorry about that but i'll go
ahead and show you what happened so I
checked the margins 900 something GP and
666 coins with margin so I instant sold
27 m for 666 made about 18 K so then 60
/ the two minutes that it took 30 times
the 18k that I made and we get 540k so
that's 540k in an hour if you instant
sell them ok and additionally i checked
margins again and they're pretty steady
and so if you did were to sell them for
the nine hundred coins each and you x 2
x the 27 that you get you can make about
let's see 30 x 24 300 and you get 730 k
so you can make up words of 730 k you
just do this method so that's it guys
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
my next video
[Music]